[Musique]
antoine bonjour alors parler nous donnez
nous plus de détails sur ces fameux
super crs bonjour alors nos confrères
d'europe 1 ont donc révélé la semaine
dernière
cette nouvelle compagnie de crs dit
d'élite donc devait voir le jour d'ici
l'été
la ffr pour force d'appui rapide donc
surnommée la super si elle reste cette
nouvelle force comme vous le disiez tout
à l'heure elle est composée de deux
cents fonctionnaires projetable h 24 7
jours sur 7 sur tout le territoire
qu'elle est prête à partir en théorie en
15 minutes cette nouvelle force pour
intervenir notamment parce que pas que
sur les violences urbaines ou du
rétablissement de l'ordre
un cos et ont pour le moment de cette
compagnie pour le moment l été on sait
assez peu de choses
on sait seulement que c'est super crs
seraient dotés de nouveaux matériels en
tout cas notamment des 4 4 qui peuvent
franchir des barricades des cas ce que
plus léger des équipements ignifuges et
pour le feu on sait aussi que la crs 8
sera concerné par ce changement situe à
bièvres en région parisienne elle se
serait transformée pour devenir donc la
ffr et selon france info
cet autre compagnie du même type
pourraient voir le jour d'ici d'ici la
fin de l'année suivante alors du côté
des premiers concernés à savoir les crs
comment est-ce qu'on accueille cette
innovation alors j'ai pu m'entretenir
avec un syndicaliste hilaire s'appelle
michael duval qui est délégué zonal
autres france pour unsa police crs est
jugé notamment demander si cette
nouveauté allait susciter des vocations
puisqu'on parle d'unité d'élite
il m'a répondu prudemment que pour le
moment c'était plutôt mitigé en fait
même s'il a reconnu que l'adjectif
d'élite effectivement qui était accolé
donc à la fr pouvait tenter quelques
collègues les attirer vers cette
nouvelle force mais en tant que crs et
en tant que représentant syndical lui
c'est plutôt inquiété de savoir en
premièrement comment les membres de
cette force allait être rétribués parce
que ça c'est la grande question auxerre
est ce que les indemnités journalières
d'absence temporaire les ij at ça compte
beaucoup dans les revenus du crs on
avait parlé à une époque pendant les
gilet jaune c'est 40 euros par jour
à partir de 12 heures de déplacement
donc il a résumé au téléphone si vous
voulez pour moi un crs 106 jatte
c'est plus vraiment à ceyreste par
ailleurs on sent le crs assez perplexe
quant à l'emploi de cette nouvelle force
dans l'annnonce de création sans
peut-être un contenu c'est un coup de
com de la part de boulot en réaction aux
violences urbaines observer d'abord à
dijon au mois de juin puis plus
récemment pendant la rave en bretagne
près de rennes avec une difficulté qui a
été observé pour mettre fin à ces
événements sauvage et comme s'est
interrogé donc mon contact michael dual
si ça se passe à marseille par exemple
est-ce qu'on va vraiment envoyer bièvre
alors que il ya trois autres compagnies
sur le même secteur
enfin les représentants syndicaux donc
en tout cas l'unsa police
j'ai l'impression de cette petite
innovation elle est en réalité déjà dans
les tuyaux de beauvau et que c'est
l'actualité qu'à poussière commune le
ministère a communiqué sur ce sujet là
donc ça ça leur a pas trop plu parce
qu'il n'y a pas de concertation qui est
syndicats on sent que ça allait ça les
gêne quand même ça passe pas trop en
tout cas du côté de l'unsa
et du côté des crs ayant déjà été très
touché par locaux vides notamment dans
les cantonnements ils n'ont pas très
envie de nouveaux matériels ils ont
plutôt envie de meilleures conditions de
travail
c'est pas forcément ceux les crs
attendait voilà merci antoine boitel des
supers crs aux superpouvoirs peut-être
avec cet article 24 qui a disparu ce
sera l'objet d'une autre discussion
entre nous merci en tout cas pour votre
expertise a retrouvé sur rt france.fr
arte sur le web